This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you look down the history of the world, you see a pattern repeat itself over and over again. For lengthy periods of time, groups, communities, and even nations can find themselves stuck. Years go by, sometimes decades, even centuries, and nothing shifts. And then a small group of people, sometimes even just one or two, decide they've had enough and start to foment change. At first, it looks impossible. The odds are too steep, the opposition too strong. But then, the impossible happens.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。如果你审视世界历史，你会发现一个模式在不断重复。在很长一段时间里，群体、社区甚至国家可能会发现自己陷入了停滞。岁月流逝，有时是几十年，甚至几个世纪，一切都没有改变。然后，一小群人，有时甚至只有一两个人，决定他们受够了，并开始煽动变革。起初，这看起来是不可能的。胜算太小，阻力太大。但随后，不可能的事情发生了。
And soon after, the change that seemed impossible appears like it was inevitable. In our story last week, we explored the psychology of learned helplessness. When people are shown over and over that they cannot change their lives or circumstances, they eventually stopped trying to bring about change in their lives and circumstances. If you miss that story, you can find it in our podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. It's titled How to Make a Difference, Part 1. Today, we look at the psychology of people who bring about change in their own lives or at a level of groups and nations.
不久之后，那些看似不可能的变革看起来就像是必然会发生的。在我们上周的故事中，我们探讨了习得性无助的心理学。当人们一次又一次地被证明无法改变自己的生活或处境时，他们最终停止了尝试去改变自己的生活和处境。如果你错过了那个故事，你可以在我们的播客订阅源或 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它。它的标题是《如何有所作为，第一部分》。今天，我们来看看那些在自己生活中，或在群体和国家层面上带来变革的人的心理。
What prompts these brave souls to attempt to change their circumstances, even when it looks difficult or impossible? The evidence suggests that these individuals possess a powerful weapon. They have an internal sense of agency. By believing that change is possible, by believing that they can be agents of change, they create a force field that actually makes change possible. Today on the show, we explore research that shows that a capacity for agency is not a personality trait,
是什么促使这些勇敢的灵魂去尝试改变他们的处境，即使这看起来很困难或不可能？证据表明，这些人拥有一种强大的武器。他们有一种内在的能动性意识。通过相信变革是可能的，通过相信他们可以成为变革的推动者，他们创造了一个力场，使变革真正成为可能。今天在节目中，我们探讨的研究表明，能动性的能力不是一种人格特质，
but a skill that can be taught and learned. If we can learn to be helpless, apathetic and passive, we can also learn to be optimistic and agentic. The surprising science of how people come to see opportunity where others see only roadblocks. This week, on Hidden Brain. When we think about success, we usually focus on ingredients like talent, intelligence, and opportunity.
而是一种可以被教授和学习的技能。如果我们能学会变得无助、冷漠和被动，我们也能学会变得乐观和具有能动性。关于人们如何在他人只看到障碍的地方看到机会的惊人科学。本周，在《隐藏的大脑》中。当我们思考成功时，我们通常关注天赋、智力和机会等因素。
But psychologists have found that another factor matters just as much or even more. Before we ever take action, we carry around assumptions about whether our actions can make a difference. Those assumptions can determine whether we persist and adapt or never make an attempt in the first place. At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Martin Seligman studies how people can learn to be more agentic.
但心理学家发现，另一个因素同样重要，甚至更重要。在我们采取行动之前，我们总是带着关于我们的行动是否能带来改变的假设。这些假设可以决定我们是坚持和适应，还是从一开始就从未尝试过。在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）研究人们如何学习变得更具能动性。
Marty Seligman, welcome to Hidden Brain. I'm delighted to be here. Marty, in your early days as a professor, you had a brilliant student whom you call Suzanne, describe her for me and tell me how she responded when you placed a significant challenge before her. In my earliest years as a professor, my policy with students generally has been, after they've shown they were A-plus students in my courses, is to treat them as a post-doc graduate student and give them really difficult problems.
马蒂·塞利格曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。我很高兴来到这里。马蒂，在你担任教授的早期，你有一位出色的学生，你称她为苏珊，请描述一下她，并告诉我当你给她提出一个重大挑战时，她是如何反应的。在我担任教授的最初几年，我对学生的政策通常是，在他们证明自己是课程中的优等生后，就把他们当作博士后研究生来对待，并给他们一些非常困难的问题。
So this happened with one of my terrific students, I'll call her Suzanne, and she started to work on the problem. And eventually I saw her with her head in her hands, crying, sobbing. She had given up. It was too hard for her. Well, my thinking at the time was, what did psychology tell us about giving us? up and how we can get rid of it. And this is indeed, in many ways, the start of the arc of my 60 years of work, which started with helplessness and giving up. But halfway through became the opposite question. How do we make people more agentic and happier? In many ways, Suzanne's example is not the
所以这发生在我的一位出色的学生身上，我称她为苏珊，她开始着手解决这个问题。最终我看到她双手抱头，哭泣、啜泣。她放弃了。这对她来说太难了。嗯，我当时的想法是，心理学告诉我们关于放弃的什么，以及我们如何摆脱它。这确实在很多方面是我60年工作历程的起点，始于无助和放弃。但中途变成了相反的问题。我们如何让人们更具能动性、更快乐？在很多方面，苏珊的例子并不是
example of someone who was lazy or incompetent because in some way she had demonstrated that she was a good student in your class previously. And so it must have been a little puzzling when you saw her suddenly throw up her hands and give up because in some ways this was not the giving up of someone who truly was unable to do the problem. It was somebody who had given up almost before they started. If you have the talent of Mozart, but you don't believe you can compose, music. The result is zero. But psychology at that time had three huge blind spots about human beings, which made it impossible to ask questions about helplessness and mastery. The first blind spot was misery versus happiness. So psychology was entirely about
一个懒惰或无能的人的例子，因为她在某种程度上之前已经在你的课堂上证明了她是一个好学生。所以当你看到她突然摊开双手放弃时，一定有点令人困惑，因为在某种程度上，这并不是一个真正无法解决问题的人的放弃。这是一个几乎在开始之前就放弃了的人。如果你有莫扎特的天赋，但你不相信你能作曲，结果就是零。但当时的心理学对人类有三个巨大的盲点，这使得询问关于无助和掌控的问题变得不可能。第一个盲点是痛苦与幸福。所以心理学完全是关于
the relief of misery. But when you lie in bed at night, you're not thinking about how when you go from minus 8 to minus 3. You're thinking about happiness, doing better, how to go from plus 2 to plus 5. Psychology didn't have a science of going from plus 2 to plus 5. The second blind spot was determinism, and that we were puppets of the environment, and that notions like deliberation, choice, and preference made no sense. And the third blind spot was thinking itself. So it wasn't until the 21st century with positive psychology and cognitive psychology and cognitive psychology, that psychology began to work constructively on happiness, on freedom and choice, and on cognition. I couldn't deal with Suzanne in 1969, but now psychology can deal with a Mozart
缓解痛苦。但当你晚上躺在床上时，你不会考虑如何从负8变成负3。你在考虑幸福，做得更好，如何从正2变成正5。心理学没有一门关于从正2变成正5的科学。第二个盲点是决定论，即我们是环境的傀儡，诸如审议、选择和偏好之类的概念毫无意义。第三个盲点是思维本身。因此，直到21世纪，随着积极心理学、认知心理学和认知心理学的出现，心理学才开始在幸福、自由和选择以及认知方面进行建设性的工作。我在1969年无法处理苏珊的问题，但现在心理学可以处理一个莫扎特，
who has the talent but believes that he can't compose music. During that early part of Marty's career, he learned about a research project that had been carried out in a nursing home. The facility was planning to redecorate a floor that served patients with developmental disabilities. It moved the residents down to the first floor. The change made a striking difference for one particular resident. And they moved her down, and on the first floor, there were a lot of things you could do. And suddenly, for the first time, she started to blossom. She spoke for the first time. She helped in the cooking. About two weeks later, the third floor redecoration was complete.
他有天赋但认为自己不能作曲。在马蒂职业生涯的早期，他了解到一个在疗养院进行的研究项目。该设施计划重新装修一层为发育障碍患者服务的楼层。它将居民搬到了二楼。这一变化对一位特定的居民产生了显著的影响。他们把她搬下来，在一楼，有很多事情你可以做。突然间，她第一次开始绽放。她第一次开口说话。她帮忙做饭。大约两周后，三楼的重新装修完成了。
The woman and the other patients who had been moved to the first floor moved back to their original rooms. She immediately died within a few days. And this inspired Ellen Langer and Judy Rodin to see what was really going on. Now, in the background, we had discovered learned helplessness in people and animals. And we had the first indications that helplessness made you ill, that it took away from you physically.
这位女士和其他被搬到一楼的病人搬回了他们原来的房间。她在几天内就去世了。这启发了艾伦·兰格（Ellen Langer）和朱迪·罗丁（Judy Rodin）去看看究竟发生了什么。现在，在背景中，我们已经在人和动物身上发现了习得性无助。我们有了最初的迹象，表明无助会让你生病，它在生理上夺走了你的东西。
So here's what Judy and Ellen did. They went to one floor of a nursing home, and they gave a speech to all the residents. And it was of the form, we want you to find out about all the things you can do for yourself at Shady Gras. You can choose whether or not to go to the movies on Tuesday night or Thursday night. You can choose whether or not to have lunch at one or two. Here's a group of plants. Pick out a plant, but you take care of it and water it. On the first floor of the nursing home, they gave a different speech.
所以朱迪和艾伦做了以下事情。他们去了疗养院的一层，并向所有居民发表了演讲。演讲的形式是，我们希望你们了解在谢迪格罗夫（Shady Grove）你们可以为自己做的一切。你们可以选择周二晚上或周四晚上是否去看电影。你们可以选择一点或两点吃午饭。这是一组植物。选一盆植物，但你要照顾它并给它浇水。在疗养院的一层，他们发表了不同的演讲。
We want you to know all the things we're going to do for you here at Shady Grove. Tuesday night is movie night, lunch is at 1 o'clock, and the nurse is going to pick out a plant, which will be nice in your room, but she's going to water it. Then they did two things. This was back in the days when psychology was done with paper clips and rubber bands. We didn't have motion detectors. They put on white adhesive tape on the wheelchair, and over two weeks they measure. how dirty it got, which was the motion to texture. But most importantly, they measured death.
我们希望你们知道我们在这里为你们做的一切。周二晚上是电影之夜，午餐在一点钟，护士会选一盆植物，放在你们房间里会很好看，但她会给它浇水。然后他们做了两件事。这还是在心理学用回形针和橡皮筋完成的年代。我们没有运动探测器。他们在轮椅上贴了白色胶带，两周内他们测量它变得多脏，这就是运动探测器。但最重要的是，他们测量了死亡。
And they found that a statistically larger sample of people died on the first floor than on the third floor. And they found that on the third floor, there was motion. People did things. The adhesive tape was black. And this opened the field of the positive. psychology of health. I mean, in some ways, it's striking because the options that people had at the nursing home on the third floor and the first floor were actually the same. I mean, people had plants, they were movies, there was food to eat. But the difference was that the people on the third floor had choice.
他们发现，一楼死亡的样本在统计学上比三楼多。他们发现，在三楼，有运动。人们做了事情。胶带是黑色的。这开启了健康积极心理学的领域。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这很引人注目，因为人们在疗养院三楼和一楼的选择实际上是一样的。我的意思是，人们有植物，有电影，有食物吃。但区别在于三楼的人有选择权。
And they were told, you not only have choice, but you have responsibility. You have to take care of this plant. And if you don't take care of the plant, the plant's going to die. And on the first floor, they had all the things. They had a beautiful plant in the room, but things were being done for their. almost out of, you could argue, love, but you could argue that this love was misplaced because the people on the third floor ended up doing much better because they had agency, they had options, they had choice.
他们被告知，你们不仅有选择权，而且有责任。你们必须照顾这盆植物。如果你们不照顾这盆植物，植物就会死。而在二楼，他们拥有所有东西。房间里有一盆漂亮的植物，但事情都是为他们做的。几乎出于，你可以说是爱，但你可以说这种爱放错了地方，因为三楼的人最终做得好得多，因为他们有能动性，他们有选择，他们有选择权。
Notice there are two things going on between the first floor and the third floor. Is it the presence of agency that increases well-being, health, and activity, or is it the absence of agency, helplessness that kills you? It's taken 60 years to unravel that puzzle. So what we thought for the first 40 years was that the crucial thing was that helplessness killed you. But could it have been the opposite, that it was mastery that saved your life and that helplessness is a default response.
注意一楼和三楼之间有两件事在发生。是能动性的存在增加了幸福感、健康和活动，还是能动性的缺失，即无助感杀死了你？解开这个谜团花了60年。所以我们在前40年里认为，关键在于无助感杀死了你。但会不会是相反的，是掌控感拯救了你的生命，而无助感是一种默认反应。
And the great work of Steve Mayer in the last 25 years discovered that we were wrong about learned helplessness. And wrong in the sense that really it was the presence of agency that was making the difference, not the presence of helplessness that was making things worse. Yes. Steve was able to find out through a brilliant series of neuroscience experiments, that the active force was the learning of agency,
史蒂夫·迈耶（Steve Mayer）在过去25年里的伟大工作发现，我们对习得性无助的理解是错误的。错误在于，实际上是能动性的存在带来了改变，而不是无助的存在让事情变得更糟。是的。史蒂夫通过一系列精彩的神经科学实验发现，积极的力量是能动性的学习，
not the learning of helplessness. The most powerful obstacles are not always the ones we can see. The most dangerous oppressors are not the ones holding guns to our head. Sometimes the greatest barrier to change is our own conviction that nothing we do can alter the outcome. There is no battle to be won or lost, because we've thrown in the towel before the battle even begins. When we come back, strategies for strengthening the belief that our actions can make a difference. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
而不是无助的学习。最强大的障碍并不总是我们能看到的。最危险的压迫者不是那些用枪指着我们头的人。有时，变革最大的障碍是我们自己坚信我们所做的一切都无法改变结果。没有战斗可以赢或输，因为我们在战斗开始之前就已经认输了。当我们回来时，我们将探讨增强我们相信自己的行动能带来改变的信念的策略。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us assume that when a discouraging thought pops into our minds, it's telling us the truth. This won't work. I'm not cut out for this. It's too hard. But what if those thoughts are less like facts and more like hypotheses? Stories our minds have learned to tell. Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. He studies the science of human flourishing. Marty, in our companion episode last week, we talked about the power of our explanatory styles.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们许多人认为，当一个令人沮丧的想法出现在我们脑海中时，它是在告诉我们真相。这行不通。我不适合做这个。这太难了。但如果这些想法不像事实，而更像是假设呢？我们的思想学会讲述的故事。马丁·塞利格曼是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。他研究人类繁荣的科学。马蒂，在我们上周的配套剧集中，我们谈到了我们解释风格的力量。
Let's go over that one more time. What are explanatory styles? Explanatory styles are the reflexive automatic ways that you think about the causes of adversity that happens to you. And so, for example, if you're rejected by your girlfriend, you might think, I'm unlovable. On the other hand, you might think, she's a horrible. Well, the consequences are very different. different of what you think. In both cases, you've been rejected by someone you love. But in one case, she's a horrible. You search for love again. In the other case, I'm unlovable. You give up and become
让我们再复习一遍。什么是解释风格？解释风格是你思考发生在你身上的逆境原因的反射性、自动化的方式。例如，如果你被女朋友拒绝了，你可能会想，我不可爱。另一方面，你可能会想，她是个糟糕的人。嗯，后果是非常不同的。在两种情况下，你都被你爱的人拒绝了。但在一种情况下，她是个糟糕的人。你再次寻找爱。在另一种情况下，我不可爱。你放弃并变得
helpless. And it was that observation that got me interested in optimism. And indeed, I spent 30 years of my life working on the question of how you build optimism. Marty, you say that one way to cultivate our sense of agency is to shift our explanatory style away from the tendency to catastrophize. Can you unpack that idea for me? Yes. Very importantly, for good evolutionary reason, we are catastrophizers. And here's the reason.
无助。正是这种观察让我对乐观主义产生了兴趣。事实上，我花了30年的时间研究如何建立乐观主义。马蒂，你说培养我们能动性意识的一种方法是将我们的解释风格从灾难化的倾向中转移出来。你能为我拆解这个想法吗？是的。非常重要的一点是，出于良好的进化原因，我们是灾难化者。原因如下。
The last major geological age was the Ice Ages, the Pliocene. And those of our ancestors who said, it's a gorgeous day in Philadelphia today, I'll bet it's going to be gorgeous tomorrow, got crushed by the ice. Those of our ancestors who said, it's a nice day in Philadelphia today, but it's an illusion. The ice is coming, drought is coming, flood is coming, disease is coming, lived and passed on their genes. So we inherited a brain that automatically goes to catastrophization. We are by nature catastrophizers and pessimists. So the question is, well, what can you do about a brain that is always telling you the most catastrophic.
上一个主要的地质时代是冰河时代，即上新世。我们那些说，费城今天天气真好，我敢打赌明天也会很好的祖先，被冰雪压垮了。我们那些说，费城今天天气不错，但这是一种幻觉。冰雪要来了，干旱要来了，洪水要来了，疾病要来了的祖先，活了下来并传递了他们的基因。所以我们继承了一个自动转向灾难化的大脑。我们天生就是灾难化者和悲观主义者。所以问题是，好吧，对于一个总是告诉你最灾难性的、
Introthrific interpretation. One of the potent exercises is put it in perspective. Noon on Friday. You get a message from your manager. Please come see me at 4 o'clock. What do you think? I'm going to get fired. I'm going to get fired. This is it. How do you counter? that catastrophic explanation. So here's what we do systematically. First, we have people get in touch with their catastrophic brain. Tell me the very worst thing that could happen.
最可怕的解释的大脑，你能做什么？其中一个有效的练习是将其置于视角中。周五中午。你收到经理的一条信息。请在4点钟来见我。你怎么想？我要被解雇了。我要被解雇了。就是这样。你如何反驳那种灾难性的解释？所以我们系统地这样做。首先，我们让人们与他们灾难化的大脑接触。告诉我可能发生的最糟糕的事情。
Well, she read my memo about the marketing campaign. She hates it, and I'm going to be fired. Okay. Now, tell me the very best thing. that could happen at 4 o'clock. She read the memo. She loved it. I'm going to be promoted.
嗯，她读了关于营销活动的备忘录。她讨厌它，我要被解雇了。好的。现在，告诉我4点钟可能发生的最好的事情。
I'm getting a raise. Okay. Now tell me the most realistic thing that's likely to happen. Well, she read the memo. She had reservations about my budget, which was probably overly optimistic. And she's likely to say she likes the basic idea, but she's going to make major cuts in the budget.
她读了备忘录。她很喜欢。我要被提拔了。
Okay, that's the most likely scenario. Now, tell me how you're going to plan for the 4 o'clock meeting. I'm going to go over the budget again. She's probably going to tell me it should be slashed by 40%. I'm going to show her the items that will keep it to 20%. So basically, by having people be in touch with catastrophizing, then countering it with the equally unrealistic, what's the best case, brings them to the average case. The voices that you hear, the catastrophization voices, are not voices of reality. They're voices that come from the ice ages that are announced.
我要加薪了。好的。现在告诉我最可能发生的最现实的事情。嗯，她读了备忘录。她对我的预算有保留意见，这可能过于乐观了。她很可能会说她喜欢基本想法，但她会大幅削减预算。
to someone who's a rival for your boyfriend and wants to make your life miserable. So you can't treat your automatic thoughts as if they were true. And that's one of the basic discoveries of positive psychology and agency. I understand, Marty, that you've spent much of your own life as a pessimist. Have you managed to shift your own explanatory style? Indeed, I have, and I'm still learning these days, Chunker. So, indeed, I'm very good at countering my four in the morning pessimistic thoughts. And indeed, I woke up at four in the morning last night.
好的，这是最可能的情况。现在，告诉我你打算如何为4点的会议做准备。我要再检查一遍预算。她很可能会告诉我应该削减40%。我要向她展示那些能将其保持在20%的项目。所以基本上，通过让人们接触灾难化，然后用同样不现实的最好情况来反驳它，将他们带到了平均情况。你听到的声音，灾难化的声音，不是现实的声音。它们是来自冰河时代的声音，是对
Oh, my God, I've got this three-hour interview with Chunker. I'm almost 84 years old. You know, he's up on the literature. I just remember the gist of the literature. Sure, I can't go through with this tomorrow. So I heard that voice at 4 in the morning. The voice is never going to go away, but I've gotten very good at arguing against it. And so I said, hey, wait a minute.
你男朋友的竞争对手宣布的，想让你的生活变得悲惨。所以你不能把你的自动思维当作真实。这是积极心理学和能动性的基本发现之一。我明白，马蒂，你一生中大部分时间都是一个悲观主义者。你是否成功地改变了自己的解释风格？确实，我已经改变了，而且我还在学习，尚卡尔。所以，确实，我非常擅长反驳我凌晨四点的悲观想法。事实上，我昨晚凌晨四点醒来。
I just did a major interview last week. I was the same age. It went beautifully. And I knew the stuff at least as well as my interviewer. And then you may not have noticed today. We had technical trouble before. In the technical trouble, you and I warmed up together. And I saw how friendly you were.
哦，天哪，我和尚卡尔有一个三小时的采访。我快84岁了。你知道，他了解文献。我只记得文献的要点。当然，我明天无法完成这个。所以我凌晨四点听到了那个声音。那个声音永远不会消失，但我已经非常擅长反驳它了。所以我说，嘿，等一下。
And so I argued against it even as we started. But very importantly, even at this age, I keep learning about the importance of positivity. So the strategy you just told me about, which is, Contesting our catastrophic thoughts about what might happen in the future can help, of course, when we're thinking about things in the future. What do you advise we do when the catastrophic thing, so to speak, is behind us? Something has happened, and we feel like we have already failed. The way we think about the present and the past has a lot to do about how active or passive we're going to be in the future. And this is what explanatory style is about.
我上周刚做了一个重要的采访。我当时也是同样的年龄。进行得很完美。而且我了解这些东西至少和我采访者一样好。然后你今天可能没有注意到。我们之前有技术故障。在技术故障中，你和我一起热身。我看到了你是多么友好。
So the pessimist believes when a bad event occurs in the present or in the past, it's permanent. It's going to last forever. It's pervasive. It's going to ruin my life in many areas. And it's personal that I made it happen. So it's crucial to be on top of. of the way you explain bad events and your explanation about the future. So crucially, to the extent, your reflexive beliefs are, it's me, it's going to last forever,
所以我甚至在我们开始时就反驳了它。但非常重要的是，即使在这个年龄，我仍在不断学习积极性的重要性。所以你刚才告诉我的策略，即反驳我们对未来可能发生的事情的灾难性想法，当然可以在我们思考未来的事情时有所帮助。你建议我们当所谓的灾难性事情已经过去时该怎么办？事情已经发生了，我们觉得我们已经失败了。我们思考现在和过去的方式与我们在未来是主动还是被动有很大关系。这就是解释风格的意义所在。
it's going to undermine everything I do, that produces learned helplessness. It produces passivity, and it produces passivity over a long period of time. and it produces depression because it becomes general. So it's very important to learn to argue against your most catastrophic interpretations of the past so that you can flourish in the future. Marty, you say that another way we can nurture our sense of agency is to design a series of increasingly difficult tasks
所以悲观主义者认为，当现在或过去发生坏事时，它是永久的。它会永远持续下去。它是普遍的。它会毁掉我生活中的许多领域。而且它是私人的，是我造成的。所以掌握你解释坏事件的方式以及你对未来的解释至关重要。因此，至关重要的是，如果你的反射性信念是，是我，它会永远持续下去，
so that as we go along, we develop a sense of progress and a sense of confidence? You can increase your optimism and your efficacy by starting absurdly small and letting events cascade. So if you're depressed and you haven't done any housework lately and you get out of bed and you look at your kitchen,
它会破坏我所做的一切，这就会产生习得性无助。它产生被动，并且在很长一段时间内产生被动。它产生抑郁，因为它变得普遍。所以学习反驳你对过去最灾难性的解释非常重要，这样你才能在未来繁荣发展。马蒂，你说我们培养能动性意识的另一种方法是设计一系列难度递增的任务，
it's filthy, the single, is filled with dirty dishes, you go back to bed. Well, that's something you can really do something about. Take one small task, clean one cup, and put it in the cupboard. Okay, you were able to do that. It turns out when you do one thing and you gradually make it more and more difficult, that there's a domino effect. Starting gradually is important for efficacy. So agency has three components. The first component is optimism.
这样随着我们的进行，我们就会产生一种进步感和自信感？你可以通过从极其微小的事情开始并让事件连锁反应来增加你的乐观主义和效能感。所以如果你抑郁了，最近没做家务，你起床看着你的厨房，
That's the belief that you can succeed in the future. The second component is efficacy, and that's the belief you can succeed right now in a specific task, in the here and now. And the third component is innovation and imagination. And that's the range of scenarios that you can believe you achieve in the future. I understand that you use this idea of getting small wins,
它很脏，水槽里装满了脏盘子，你又回到了床上。嗯，那是你可以真正做点什么的事情。采取一个小任务，清洗一个杯子，把它放进橱柜里。好的，你能够做到这一点。事实证明，当你做一件事并逐渐使其变得越来越困难时，会产生多米诺骨牌效应。逐渐开始对效能感很重要。所以能动性有三个组成部分。第一个组成部分是乐观主义。
what you call a graded task treatment on a group of patients hospitalized with depression. Yes, we found in the very first time, we ever did with depressed people if we use graded task assignment, that we could lower the depression and increase what they did by graded task assignment. This came out of the breakthrough in phobias. And basically, the breakthrough in phobias was graded task assignment. And so it turned out, and this is what inspired us, if you're catphobic, you're agrophobic, you can't go out of the house because the grass has grown high and you're going to be attacked by a cat. What you do with great success is graded task assignment. So you first teach people to bodily
那是相信你未来能成功的信念。第二个组成部分是效能感，那是相信你现在就能在特定任务中，在此时此地取得成功的信念。第三个组成部分是创新和想象力。那是你相信未来能实现的场景范围。我明白你使用这种获得小胜利的想法，
relax. Once they've learned relaxation, you start with the easy cat. Say, imagine a person whose name is Ada cats. K-A-T-Z, but relax. And it turns out people do this well. Okay. Second task, imagine the drawing of a cat and relax in its presence. And you build up all the way to encountering a real cat, usually in between six and ten graded things. And this is the best tool we have against specific phobias. Talk about the idea, Marty, that another way to develop our sense of agency is to adopt a growth mindset. Yeah. I think Carol Dweck did the field a great service by capturing the notion of explanatory style with two words, growth and mindset. The mindset part is what we're
你称之为分级任务治疗，用于一组住院的抑郁症患者。是的，我们第一次对抑郁症患者使用分级任务分配时发现，我们可以通过分级任务分配来降低抑郁并增加他们的活动。这来自于恐惧症的突破。基本上，恐惧症的突破就是分级任务分配。所以事实证明，这启发了我们，如果你有猫恐惧症，你有广场恐惧症，你不能出家门，因为草长得很高，你会受到猫的攻击。你成功做到的就是分级任务分配。所以你首先教人们身体
talking about here, your reflexive way of thinking about the good and bad event. that occur to you. Growth means it's not permanent. It's not pervasive. And so what growth does is tell you that any failure you have now is temporary and local. But as you grow and learn more, it migrates from permanent to temporary and pervasive to local. So growth mindset is a a beautiful metaphor for what explanatory style tells us about automatic thoughts. The stories we tell ourselves can quietly expand or shrink the range of possibilities we see before us. By learning to challenge certain stories and tell more of other kinds of stories, we can build our confidence and capacity to bring about change.
放松。一旦他们学会了放松，你就从简单的猫开始。比如，想象一个名字叫Ada Cats的人。K-A-T-Z，但要放松。事实证明人们做得很好。好的。第二个任务，想象猫的画，并在它的存在下放松。你一直建立到遇到真正的猫，通常在六到十个分级任务之间。这是我们对抗特定恐惧症的最好工具。谈谈这个想法，马蒂，培养我们能动性意识的另一种方法是采用成长型思维。是的。我认为卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）用两个词，成长和思维，捕捉了解释风格的概念，为该领域做出了巨大贡献。思维部分就是我们
When we come back, how to use our imaginations to expand our sense of agency. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Has this conversation evoked your own experiences of feeling helpless? Has it reminded you of a time when you stepped up and took charge of your own destiny?
在这里谈论的，你对发生在你身上的好坏事件的反射性思考方式。成长意味着它不是永久的。它不是普遍的。所以成长所做的是告诉你，你现在经历的任何失败都是暂时的和局部的。但随着你的成长和学习更多，它会从永久变为暂时，从普遍变为局部。所以成长型思维是解释风格告诉我们关于自动思维的一个美丽的隐喻。我们告诉自己的故事可以悄悄地扩大或缩小我们面前可能性的范围。通过学习挑战某些故事并讲述更多其他种类的故事，我们可以建立我们的自信和带来变革的能力。
If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about the science of optimism and pessimism, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us. at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, how to make a difference.
当我们回来时，如何利用我们的想象力来扩大我们的能动性意识。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这次谈话是否唤起了你自己的无助经历？它是否让你想起了你挺身而出并掌控自己命运的时刻？
Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. He's the author of many books, including Agency, the Psychological History of Human Progress. Marty, in our conversation last week, you told me that one of the components of agency is imagination. I want to talk about some of the ways we can expand our imaginations in the service of cultivating a sense of agency.
如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者关于乐观主义和悲观主义科学的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们。地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行，如何有所作为。
you see that one strategy is to write about your best possible self? One of the techniques that we use, particularly to increase optimism and efficacy, is to write about your best possible self. And what that can unleash is a set of scenarios about your future that have not occurred before. Now, since agency has three components, efficacy, optimism, and imagination, And we know a great deal about increasing optimism. We know a fair amount about increasing efficacy. I'm very interested in the question of increasing imagination.
再说一遍，是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。马丁·塞利格曼是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。他是许多书的作者，包括《能动性：人类进步的心理学历史》。马蒂，在我们上周的谈话中，你告诉我能动性的组成部分之一是想象力。我想谈谈我们可以用来扩大想象力以服务于培养能动性意识的一些方法。
My late colleague, Danny Conneman, distinguishes between system one, which is intuition, and system two, which is deliberation. here's what I found. Just one story sums it up. A Nobelist from the University of Durham. His field, what he was the genius of, is how do biological systems order random physical events. So here's what he said. He had a vision at age 25 of a pudding, gillow, that's vibrating, and it recruits biscuits to stiffen it up. System 1, intuition. He spends the next 30 years in deliberation. That is, mathematicizing that vision.
你认为一个策略是写下你最好的自我？我们使用的技术之一，特别是为了增加乐观主义和效能感，是写下你最好的自我。这可以释放出一系列关于你未来的、以前从未发生过的场景。现在，由于能动性有三个组成部分，效能感、乐观主义和想象力。而且我们对增加乐观主义了解很多。我们对增加效能感了解不少。我对增加想象力的问题非常感兴趣。
So for me, a lot of imagination and creativity has to do with something we don't know about. And that's how to make people's intuitions more creative. Now, given that, I think your listeners would want to know what the usual techniques are. And let me just go through some of the techniques which improve creative performance at least a little bit. So if you're a writer, for example, one technique is to develop what-if scenarios in which there are multiple endings and then choose a month. the endings. Mind wandering is probably pretty important for intuition. So daydreaming and dreaming are related to creativity and more than one of my turns in life had to do with dreaming and to find a situation that's most conducive. Keep background noise low. Keep lighting. Keep lighting.
我已故的同事，丹尼·卡尼曼（Danny Kahneman），区分了系统一，即直觉，和系统二，即审议。这是我发现的。仅仅一个故事就总结了它。一位来自达勒姆大学的诺贝尔奖得主。他的领域，他是天才的领域，是生物系统如何排序随机物理事件。所以他是这样说的。他在25岁时对布丁、果冻有了一个愿景，它在振动，它招募饼干来加固它。系统一，直觉。他接下来的30年都在审议。也就是说，将那个愿景数学化。
dim and above all, move it physically. But if there's any disappointment I have in the entire agency literature is we don't have a killer app for imagination. And when someone tells you they've got one, hold on to your wallet. Talk a moment about this idea of writing about your best possible self. What does it involve? How would you do it, Marty? There are lots of ways in, One thing I like to do, particularly with non-depressed people, is have a person write their own obituary for their grandchildren. And what that particular technique, by the way, we don't do this with depressed people, it's obituary, sets all sorts of awful stuff. But imagining your most successful future and you root to how you.
所以对我来说，很多想象力和创造力与我们不知道的事情有关。那就是如何让人们的直觉更具创造性。现在，鉴于此，我想你的听众会想知道通常的技术是什么。让我列举一些至少能稍微提高创造性表现的技术。所以如果你是一名作家，例如，一种技术是开发假设场景，其中有多个结局，然后选择一个结局。思维游离对于直觉可能相当重要。所以白日梦和做梦与创造力有关，我人生中的不止一个转折点与做梦有关，并找到最有利的情况。保持背景噪音低。保持照明。保持照明。
got there is the basic structure of writing about the best possible self. You also talk about the idea that if we can't imagine ourselves having agency, one of the things that we can do is to expand our vision of what is possible by emulating others who have succeeded, especially others who are like us. Talk about this idea, Marty. Yes. One of the techniques for imagination is that is to get to know people or to read about people who are like you, who have encountered a lot of obstacles, and see what they do. In my own life, reading Winston Churchill and reading Abraham Lincoln, all the biographies have been very instructive for me about how to make new departures under adversity. Marty, you tell a couple of stories about people you know who have found creative ways to expand their agency.
昏暗，最重要的是，物理上移动它。但如果我在整个能动性文献中有什么失望的话，那就是我们没有想象力的杀手级应用。当有人告诉你他们有一个时，捂好你的钱包。谈谈写下你最好的自我的想法。它涉及什么？你会怎么做，马蒂？有很多进入的方法，我喜欢做的一件事，特别是对于非抑郁的人，是让一个人为他们的孙辈写他们自己的讣告。顺便说一句，那种特定的技术，我们不对抑郁的人做这个，它是讣告，设置了各种可怕的东西。但想象你最成功的未来以及你如何
The first was a young woman who was working her way through college as a waitress. What was the approach that she took? I've been very interested in signature strengths and using signature strengths at work. There's a two-part exercise that really helps here, and I can illustrate it with a woman who was a student of mine and a waitress. But the first part is you have to know what your highest strengths are, your signature strengths. And here's something I recommend for your listeners. I have a free website called Authentic Happiness, One Word.org. At least 10 million people have registered at the website. And one of the tests is,
到达那里是写下最好的自我的基本结构。你还谈到了如果我们不能想象自己拥有能动性，我们可以做的一件事是通过效仿那些已经成功的人，特别是那些像我们一样的人，来扩大我们对可能性的愿景。谈谈这个想法，马蒂。是的。想象力的技术之一是去了解人或阅读关于像你一样的人，他们遇到了很多障碍，看看他们做了什么。在我自己的生活中，阅读温斯顿·丘吉尔和阅读亚伯拉罕·林肯，所有的传记对我来说都非常有启发，关于如何在逆境中做出新的出发。马蒂，你讲了几个关于你认识的人找到创造性方法来扩大他们能动性的故事。
the via signature strength test. This is a test that at least five million people have taken now that tells you what your highest strengths are. So once you know what your highest strengths are, social intelligence, humor, generosity, etc., the question is to use them more at work. Now, one of my students, one of my graduate students was a waitress. She hated waitressing. heavy trays, being patronized by customers, ignored. So she took the signature strengths test, and her highest strength was social intelligence. So her assignment was to use social intelligence more at work.
第一个是一个年轻女子，她作为服务员在大学里打工。她采取的方法是什么？我一直对标志性优势和在工作中利用标志性优势非常感兴趣。这里有一个两部分的练习真的很有帮助，我可以用一个曾经是我的学生和服务员的女性来说明它。但第一部分是你必须知道你最高的优势是什么，你的标志性优势。这里有一些我为你的听众推荐的东西。我有一个免费的网站叫 Authentic Happiness，一个词.org。至少有1000万人注册了该网站。其中一个测试是，
So she resolved that she would make the encounter with her the social highlight of every customer's evening. And indeed, that's what she put on display. Now, obviously, it didn't work all the time, but it worked enough, so the tips were bigger, trays were lighter, and waitressing became fun. So the important thing about using your signature strengths is it not only produces more productivity at work, but a lot more positive emotion and less negative emotion. Find out what you're best at and use it, divert your work to use it more.
VIA标志性优势测试。这是一个至少有500万人参加过的测试，它告诉你你最高的优势是什么。所以一旦你知道你最高的优势是什么，社交智能、幽默、慷慨等，问题就是要在工作中更多地利用它们。现在，我的一个学生，我的一个研究生是一名服务员。她讨厌做服务员。沉重的托盘，被顾客居高临下地对待，被忽视。所以她参加了标志性优势测试，她最高的优势是社交智能。所以她的任务是在工作中更多地利用社交智能。
And in some ways it makes intuitive sense, Mardi, if we're going to exercise agency, clearly it's going to be easier for us to exercise agency in the strengths and skills that come naturally to us. Yes, I think there really is something about being a natural. And back in our first session, I talked about the advice I give to my students when they asked me about choosing a profession. And the advice I give is find the intersection of what you're naturally good at and what the world needs. Another of your students felt constrained by the fact that he had a long walk home through an unsafe neighborhood each night after he finished studying at the library. he came up with an approach to give himself a feeling of agency that I thought was very imaginative. Tell me what he did, Marty.
所以她决定让与她的接触成为每个顾客晚上社交的亮点。事实上，这就是她所展示的。现在，显然，它并不总是有效，但它足够有效，所以小费更多了，托盘更轻了，做服务员变得很有趣。所以利用你的标志性优势的重要之处在于，它不仅能提高工作效率，还能产生更多的积极情绪和更少的消极情绪。找出你最擅长什么并利用它，转移你的工作以更多地利用它。
Well, again, he took the signature strength test, and for him, he was a hard worker. He studied in Van Pelt Library until midnight, and then had to walk through the most dangerous areas of Philadelphia for almost 40 minutes to get home again. There's the worst part of his day. He took the signature strength test, and his highest strength was humor and playfulness. So the assignment I gave him was to use humor and playfulness to take the walk home at midnight. So he bought a pair of rollerblades and a stopwatch, and he declared at an Olympic event and timed himself every night to get home. He loved doing that, and then each night he was trying to break his own record to get home. It removed the fear from a dangerous walk in his mind, and it became the highlight of his day.
在某种程度上，这在直觉上是有道理的，马蒂，如果我们打算行使能动性，显然在我们自然拥有的优势和技能中行使能动性会更容易。是的，我认为成为一个自然而然的人确实有一些东西。回到我们的第一次会议，我谈到了当我的学生问我关于选择职业时我给他们的建议。我给出的建议是找到你天生擅长的事情与世界需要的事情的交集。你的另一个学生因为每天晚上在图书馆学习后必须走很长一段路穿过一个不安全的社区回家而感到受限。他想出了一种方法来给自己一种能动性的感觉，我觉得非常有想象力。告诉我是他做了什么，马蒂。
Can you talk for a moment about people who are, in fact, genuinely helpless? If struggle is in fact hopeless, if your life circumstances genuinely leave you in a bind, Is it possible that agency can ever be a curse rather than a blessing, Marty? You know, agency is double-edged. So for the last half hour with Shankar, I've been celebrating the virtues of agency. But there are downs. There's a shadow side of agency. So one of the shadow sides is that there are people who are genuinely victims and oppressed and helpless.
嗯，同样，他参加了标志性优势测试，对他来说，他是一个努力工作的人。他在范佩尔特图书馆学习到午夜，然后必须走近40分钟穿过费城最危险的地区才能再次回家。那是他一天中最糟糕的部分。他参加了标志性优势测试，他最高的优势是幽默和俏皮。所以我给他的任务是利用幽默和俏皮来完成午夜回家的路。所以他买了一双轮滑鞋和一个秒表，他宣布这是一场奥林匹克赛事，每天晚上给自己计时回家。他喜欢这样做，然后每天晚上他都在试图打破自己回家的记录。它消除了他心中危险行走的恐惧，它成为了他一天中的亮点。
and an overall sense of agency might get you to inappropriately blame them, blame the victim. So oppression and helplessness are real, and I've spent half of my life working on it. So that's an important shadow side of agency. Similarly, a shadow side of imagination is that if we can do it and we imagine we can do it, should it be done and should we think about the consequences. So when people think about atomic energy and about AI today, as I do a great deal of my time, we not only need to ask, what can it do? What's the upside?
你能谈谈那些实际上确实无助的人吗？如果挣扎确实是无望的，如果你的生活处境确实让你陷入困境，马蒂，能动性有没有可能成为一种诅咒而不是一种祝福？你知道，能动性是双刃剑。所以和尚卡尔在一起的过去半小时里，我一直在赞美能动性的美德。但也有缺点。能动性有阴暗面。所以阴暗面之一是，有些人确实是受害者，被压迫和无助，
But what are the downsides? One of the things that I want to talk about is the relationship between AI and agency. There are a great many people who feel like the rise of aviation. means that we are going to be deprived of human agency, that it's going to steal our ability to be autonomous, to make choices, to make decisions. You have a much more optimistic view of the relationship between AI and agency. Tell me how you're thinking about it, Marty. Well, first, the bottom line is that the doomsayers have the press now. And you can hear all the hypothetical, awful things that might happen. And I think that's part of responsible science.
但缺点是什么呢？我想谈论的一件事是人工智能与能动性之间的关系。有很多人觉得人工智能的兴起意味着我们将被剥夺人类的能动性，它将窃取我们自主、做出选择、做出决定的能力。你对人工智能与能动性之间的关系有着更为乐观的看法。马蒂，告诉我你是怎么想的。嗯，首先，底线是末日论者现在掌握了媒体。你可以听到所有可能发生的假设性的、可怕的事情。我认为这是负责任的科学的一部分。
and we should worry about those things. My task, as a positive psychologist, is to ask about the upside. Not what's the most catastrophic thing that might occur, but what are the best things? And I'm seeing some of those best things every day in my life. They've convinced me that the upside of AI is enormous. I'm finding that creativity is a function of two,
我们应该担心这些事情。作为一名积极心理学家，我的任务是询问积极的一面。不是最灾难性的事情可能是什么，而是最好的事情是什么？我在生活中每天都能看到其中一些最好的事情。它们让我确信人工智能的积极面是巨大的。我发现创造力是两个因素的函数，
the Wright brothers, McCartney and Lenin, that I've never had a more creative partner than Claude. I've been writing this book agency for six years. Chapter 8 of the book is about agency in ancient China, Confucius, in which agency, through the bind of Chinese thinking, is illustrated. Chapter 9 is about the Bible, the difference between the Torah, which is non-agentic, and the rest of the Bible, which is agentic. So I sent it to my editor, and she sent it back to me and said, you know, Marty, there's no transition between chapter 8 and chapter 9. I've been staring at those two chapters shocker for five years, and I couldn't see a transition. So I said to Claude, Claude, read chapter 8 and 9.
莱特兄弟、麦卡特尼和列侬，我从未有过比克劳德（Claude）更具创造力的合作伙伴。我写这本关于能动性的书已经六年了。书的第八章是关于中国古代的能动性，即孔子，其中通过中国思想的束缚阐明了能动性。第九章是关于《圣经》，即托拉（Torah）与《圣经》其余部分之间的区别，前者是非能动性的，后者是能动性的。所以我把它发给了我的编辑，她把它发回给我说，你知道吗，马蒂，第八章和第九章之间没有过渡。我盯着那两章看了五年，却看不出过渡。所以我对克劳德说，克劳德，读读第八章和第九章。
and write me a one paragraph transition. Oosh! Here's what Claude said. At the same time and across the globe that the Chinese were wrestling with the tension between individual agency and the agency of the state, the Hebrews were wrestling with a more basic question,
并为我写一段过渡。噢！克劳德是这样说的。在世界各地，当中国人正在努力解决个人能动性与国家能动性之间的紧张关系时，希伯来人正在努力解决一个更基本的问题，
the relationship between individual agency and God's agency. That was exactly right. It was just brilliant, and I couldn't see it. Now, Marty didn't end up using that bit of writing in his book, but it helped him to see a connection he couldn't see otherwise. And that insight then allowed him to write his own segue between the chapters. So for me, these machines are enormous aid. to human creativity, to my creativity.
个人能动性与上帝能动性之间的关系。那完全正确。这太精彩了，我竟然没看出来。现在，马蒂最终没有在他的书中使用那段文字，但它帮助他看到了他原本无法看到的联系。这种洞察力使他能够写出章节之间自己的衔接。所以对我来说，这些机器是人类创造力、我个人创造力的巨大辅助。
And I should say, Shanker, I wake up in the morning now, more excited than I've been in about 50 years to see what Claude and I can do together about hypotheses I've had about human psychology that could not have been tested without the massive computation of Claude and ChatGPT. Marty, you've been a professor for many decades, but you recently had a dream about being a student who had to deal with an algebra final exam. I'm pretty sure I've had the same dream as you did, but can you paint a picture for me of what happened in the dream?
我应该说，尚卡尔，我现在每天早上醒来时，比过去50年里任何时候都更兴奋，因为我想看看克劳德和我能一起做些什么，去验证我关于人类心理学的假设，如果没有克劳德和ChatGPT的大规模计算，这些假设是无法验证的。马蒂，你当教授已经几十年了，但你最近做了一个梦，梦见自己是一名必须应对代数期末考试的学生。我很确定我也做过和你一样的梦，但你能为我描绘一下梦中发生了什么吗？
These are called helplessness dreams. We all have them. They're one of a Jungian archetype about what dreams are. I actually had a similar one just the other night, and it was about algebra. And then I've gone back to the Albany Academy. It's my senior year. I have to take the SATs. I can't remember anything except basic algebra. I don't know how to do quadratic equations. I barely know what a quadratic equation is. A similar musical dream that I had recently. I love music. I find myself at Carnegie Hall. I'm a about to give a concert. I look up and I'm at the piano and I realize I don't know how to read music.
这些被称为无助感梦境。我们都有过。它们是关于梦境的荣格原型之一。事实上，就在前几天晚上，我也做了一个类似的梦，是关于代数的。我回到了奥尔巴尼学院。那是我的高三。我必须参加SAT考试。除了基础代数，我什么都不记得了。我不知道怎么做二次方程。我几乎不知道什么是二次方程。我最近还做过一个类似的音乐梦。我热爱音乐。我发现自己身处卡内基音乐厅。我正要举办一场音乐会。我抬头一看，我坐在钢琴前，意识到我根本不会看乐谱。
I don't know how to play the piano and I'm supposed to do the Homer Clevere. That Beethoven's most difficult piano. That's a dream we all have. It's built in importantly to us. We need to know what we're helpless about. But even more importantly, we need to know realistically what we can master. So when you wake up from these dreams, do you reflect on the fact that in the 80-plus years that you've lived on earth, you have mastered so much, you in fact have demonstrated so much agency, you've made such a difference, Marty? I do believe I made a difference. I went in psychology to relieve suffering. I think that was what I was at. after, but I think it was poorly articulated.
我不知道怎么弹钢琴，而我本该演奏《槌子键琴奏鸣曲》（Hammerklavier）。那是贝多芬最难的钢琴曲。那是我们都会做的梦。它在本质上植根于我们。我们需要知道我们在哪些方面感到无助。但更重要的是，我们需要现实地知道我们能掌握什么。所以当你从这些梦中醒来时，你会反思这样一个事实吗：在你活在世上的80多年里，你已经掌握了这么多东西，你实际上已经展现了如此多的能动性，你已经做出了如此大的贡献，马蒂？我相信我做出了贡献。我进入心理学领域是为了减轻痛苦。我想这就是我所追求的，但我认为它表达得不够好。
What I really wanted to work on was not suffering, but well-being and happiness. But there was no psychology of well-being and happiness. It was a huge blind spot. And so I think the difference I've made is to alert science and neuroscience to the possibility that human beings can have more agency, more mastery, and you can actually be happier tomorrow than you are today. Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. He is the author of Agency, the Psychological History of Human Progress.
我真正想研究的不是痛苦，而是幸福和快乐。但当时并没有关于幸福和快乐的心理学。这是一个巨大的盲点。所以我认为我所做的贡献是提醒科学界和神经科学界，人类可以拥有更多的能动性、更多的掌控力，而且你实际上可以比今天更快乐。马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。他是《能动性：人类进步的心理学史》（Agency: The Psychological History of Human Progress）一书的作者。
Marty, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, you're welcome, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you know someone who would find today's conversation
马蒂，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。哦，不客气，尚卡尔。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你认识的人会觉得今天的对话
interesting or useful, please share it with them. Your ambassadorship is one of the best ways to connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on the show. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有趣或有用，请与他们分享。你的推荐是我们向新听众介绍我们在节目中探讨的观点最好的方式之一。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。